Je souhaite plus que tout mr.  Wiz est un
récit moderne de contes de fées que nous
connaissons Cendrillon Je souhaite à Jack le
haricot magique plus que la vie Le petit
chaperon rouge Je souhaite à Raiponce ce qui est
merveilleux, c'est que ce sont tous ces
personnages mais repensés nous avons eu un enfant
Je veux un enfant que
tu souhaites à sa malédiction  à l'envers aller vers le
Seigneur tous les personnages vont dans le
pire chacun avec leur propre souhait et
mission tout le monde veut vivre heureux pour
toujours mais parfois ça ne se passe
pas comme ça tout le monde obtient son souhait
et puis quoi et le conte de fées c'est
vraiment excitant ça  est ce que le spectacle
a été à propos de tous ceux qui vont dans
les bois sortent une personne différente
c'est comment vous vous comportez comme un prince quel
genre de roi serez-vous j'ai été élevé pour
être charmant pas sincère les bois sont une
métaphore pour beaucoup de choses dans  la vie ce sont
vos souhaits vos rêves vos espoirs mais
aussi vos peurs le thème fait très
attention à ce que vous souhaitez parce que les
répercussions de cela ne sont peut-être pas ce que
vous avez imaginé
peut-être que je devrais '  t vient tout droit du
passé peut-être que je n'aurais pas dû assister au
bal c'est vraiment je pense qu'un voyage de
grandir à partir de comprendre ce qu'est le
monde
souhaite que vous fassiez des vœux à nos enfants
Apple la queue que vous dites c'est le
sort que les
enfants feront  Ecoutez